I was walking into a building not two
weeks ago I opened the door 10 steps
back I noticed the guys coming up with
no arms you know what I do I hold the
door and when he gets up he goes I don't
need you to do that [ __ ] and I go okay
stumpy let's watch you bite that handle
for an hour that'll be a fun [ __ ]
show I call her and she doesn't answer I
play a song through the phone oh my yeah
what song was it do you know what she
called me back and said she never called
me back I saw her a year later with a
baby yeah I just realized recently that
I definitely need a hobby because I
don't actually do anything like I do
this sometimes and that's that's it you
know the same goes for all comedians
we're either we're either doing shows or
in the hotel rooms and it's a lot of
time to kill and the truth is you can
only watch so much porn before before
you're like alright I'm gonna watch some
more but right now it hurts I gotta find
something else to do made a joke and you
said let's build a wall around Louisiana
right and that made people some people
very unhappy people be like no you you
cross the line with that joke about
building a wall I'm like do you
understand what time we're living in
here late you understand the context
like our current administration wants to
build a wall to keep people out from
like quote [ __ ] countries I'm just
saying let's put a wall around a
[ __ ] state no it's coming from Ohio
being from Cincinnati like where do you
kind of get your inspiration and guess
from your Clos you know from the streets
mostly you know I travel a lot I'm a
SoCal guy now I just picked it up from
you know fights fighting people you know
beefing like I got this you know I don't
know how's your son amazing super cute
the most the door he's not like Asian
baby cute but he's like right below that
the cutest yeah I think they're cuter
than bunnies and puppies combined and I
personally I would throw away 20 white
babies to have an Asian baby yeah that's
one thing that makes me happy you like
for it I do like that hold on I feel
better
I got nothing just knowing that
something was coming it's good I fly
every week I never buy a first-class
ticket i buy coach tickets i buy them so
much i get bumped up to first class I am
Telling You the moment I get bumped up
to first class I get washed over with
this feeling I'm like look at these
disgusting poor pieces of trash yeah
I'm so much better than everybody but
don't stand next to me dude you're gross
I dare you to come try to use the
first-class bathroom from Coach when I'm
up there because I will put my hand on
your chest and I'll send you back I'll
be like no there's a pig trough in the
back for you guys don't have fun like
that so you do it all oh yeah what else
do you do that I wear on gymnastics I do
that I mean I hear you laughing but I'm
actually pretty damn good yeah yeah yeah
I mean I could do if I wanted to I could
do six flips right here right now see ya
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam but we didn't
have these cameras right here I would
have to do minute I don't want to pay
that yeah way that cost effects so
gymnast as well gymnast I'm an animal
trainer I trained dogs I can train I'm
actually one of the few guys that can
train cats too so a lot of people what's
the coolest thing you've trained a cat
to do probably answer a phone and and
looked at my driver's license as we were
having this meeting and it says I'm 511
and he goes bro come on shake his head
then he stood up next to me and I was
like I am I tower over you come on
that's ridiculous
iced how we're over you could eat
peanuts off my head easily how tall are
you - 5 11 you work with your wife very
closely - yes how does that work cuz
she's a comedian as well she's a person
and she's a living human woman um she
allows me to touch her and she likes me
so we have a good relationship
I made a baby with her wonderful
consensual everything was cool and we
love Him he is our son he's already
training right now he's 15 weeks old
I got him lifting I got him doing
push-ups he's gonna be some you don't
want to mess with for sure well he's
gonna take after you then challenge all
these uh-oh rappers and comedians out
there real playing this man Noakes if
you want to step up and get get hit you
know what to do man you meet me at the
home depot on 6th Street downtown LA
Monday at 3 o'clock and we can see what
happens
I'm half Peruvian so so we've been
teaching him Spanish because it's part
of his heritage and I speak Spanish and
you know there's also utility and
knowing Spanish so many peoples of
course yeah and then my wife's Hungarian
which is fine and and she goes I want
him to speak Hungarian I'm like why it's
like so we can be an arms dealer or
something now you're saying that you
want a a black aggressive aggressive
[ __ ] talker in tennis yeah that'd be the
best can you please watch your language
please eat my dick okay I'm gonna have
to ask you to get over to them you
didn't really know what you were taking
though right doctor has ultimately found
some stuff in your system yeah I mean I
know what I was taking cuz I taken it
before because it's fun to get high but
um I didn't realize that I shouldn't
take a hundred hits at once hello yes
hey Dad hey buddy how you doing hey um
you got a second for me I had so much
fun reading jokes to you the other day I
got some new ones submitted can I read
them to you oh sure love jokes okay
these are just women jokes okay have you
tried the lamp already okay
how do you blind a woman I give up you
put a windshield in front of her
comedian Tom Sakura aka DJ dad mouth
gggggg dad no
it's all about the after-party man I
mean I want to give a shout out to Kim
man you are amazed and throat Zillah
Zillah yeah
let's talk about rain real quick man
over here cedar rapids here man you got
a little over inch that's nothing look
at Spencer Spencer man y'all are wet it
is so easy
what is this deck Decorah decora Decorah
they have no rain or they you just felt
lazy you didn't put like putting in the
the total welcome in this one good
morning Mercer shout out to the Bristol
stool chart I had number five that soft
blobs with clear cut edges cuz I need
fiber there you go Tom Segura Segura aka
DJ dad mouth aka duct tape dad duct tape
duct tape yeah how did you get that
people call me duct tape man thank you
cuz I always have it on me you know like
MacGyver
I'm duct tape you mouth shut I'll be
anywhere that you have a hole on you
I'll put duct tape on oh look at this
we'd like to thank our sponsors that are
in homes yes if you're looking for a
house and you have money contact or in
homes and they'll help you get it and if
some breaks we'll put duct tape on it
now I gotta ask about the get up here
you were expecting a blizzard in
Syracuse obviously no it's just I rolled
my number like this in July I don't care
if it's humid I don't care if it's a
hundred and five I wear fur because
there's an old saying happy hos eat sad
hoes don't and I try to stay happy